i know you're frightened
[Music]
you're terribly frightened by what
you've seen
but i'm not gonna lie to you
your friends are not prepared for this
fight
hawkins will fall
my friends need me
[Music]
you're not ready
[Music]
he's not going to stop
not until he's taken everyone
but i have this terrible feeling
it might not work out for us
now i just want you to watch
your friends have lost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
investigations are still ongoing into
the failures operation odin sword nail
missions resulted in the death of 12
navy seals
lieutenant commander james reese can you
outline the details of your mission
they knew we were coming regarding the
audio logs you went dark on coms roughly
four mics in
why
that's not how it went down
you okay
yeah i'm fine
headaches paranoia
memory confusion
we're gonna get through this okay
tell me what happened somebody fed us
bad intellect it's a setup
if i'm right we need to act on this
i need names if there's connection to
you and your men
i'll find it
answers
or blood
blood
where's james reese is it true your
fugitive is a navy seal there's a bunch
of people tracking you right now so just
lay low
i have 12 men flying on the caskets
right now
this is personal
oh you wanted it on the fray now
you're in the battlefield
there's evil in this world likes it
which you can't possibly imagine
james
take lucy get her out of the house now
i'm not gonna tell you again
stay off my list
okay
let's begin
i'm seeing a romance oh god i'm seeing
the initials jm monogrammed on his
pillowcases are you kidding me you slept
with jason oh
shut up
you know i always thought i was a little
psychic are you doing the reading or no
just put your hands on it
you will fall in love it's gonna be
unlike anything you've ever experienced
it'll be a wedding and a family
[Music]
you
okay i got this feeling
i'm not supposed to see my own future
it's never happened before i was married
with a kid no way
you have to like talk to people to get
married
this is a happy thing why are you
fighting that you have been my psychic
since i was in seventh grade [ __ ] don't
age me like that okay relationships have
been impossible for me and this is me
high-fiving an elephant's paw ow what's
that like it's kind of hard to explain
but it's like when two people
you know as well as i do that the future
always shows up whether you want it to
or not hi
i'm the new neighbor jesse don't worry
babe i saved the heavy boxes for you ben
maggie hi what are you doing here i live
here i live here now with jesse i did
not see that coming
there's no picnic raising a psychic no
woman needs her teen daughter
forecasting her hot flashes like the
weather report
that was actually helpful
[Music]
i saw myself ending up with ben i was
wrong and i end up alone there are some
perks to being single oh i haven't
gotten tongue in a while that being said
it sounds like a nightmare and i
wouldn't wish it on my worst enemy
[Music]
your problem is you can see the future
but you never see past it what's past
the future hope honey
[Music]
this is gonna be good
[Music]
the technology to save our world is
coming
over the last century we have turned a
corner
we are on the verge of the climate that
no longer seeks to destroy us
the mission of moonhaven isn't simply
about solving the crushing problems of
our planet
it's about solving us
welcome to moon haven
moon heaven isn't a people
it's a purpose
it takes a while to get used to this
i get that this is supposed to be our
future
when i know
darkness finds a way
hasn't been a murder here in a long time
now there are two earth extremists have
found a way to get an agent on the moon
the earth will kill us all they're
earthers amongst us causing chaos
and your pilot is involved bella helps
us
she's not what she seems to be we don't
survive in spite of our wounds
we survived because of them
we all of us have been raised to believe
in this mission with all of our hearts
and minds
if we cannot heal the dark heart of
bella's way
how can we ever hope to succeed
i don't know who to trust
trust me
i never wanted this for you
i wanted a totally different life
a steady paycheck
kids
a family
[Music]
dad
tell me there's a way out of this
not a quick one
[Music]
we would like you to transfer to another
prison and befriend someone
to elicit a confession
[Music]
we suspect that this man killed 14 women
but we only have one of the bodies
[Music]
larry has vivid dreams
tell me about them in my dreams that
kill women
those are just dreams
[Music]
in this prison where the guy is
maximum security specializing in the
criminally insane
you want me to check into hell
and befriend the demon
[Music]
for all the money in the world
how about freedom
paul's convictions on appeal
he could win and walk
you had the chance to stop him
don't approach him too early or he'll
know we sent you for him
why are you looking at me like that
like you know me
if it gets out there you're here to
snitch
that's going to be a very unfortunate
day
accelerate your timetable
if he walks he'll kill
again and again
if you think you could be in danger
you are in danger
oh
[Music]
[Music]
there are only six episodes left of
better call saul the next new episode
premieres monday july 11th on amc and
amc plus
oh wow
look at you
that is the baby colin robinson i assume
i can mow this boy into the most
interesting adult there has ever been he
really loves
musical theater what have the dark lord
wrought
[Applause]
this is the big opening of our nightclub
we want the dreams to be very expensive
so then we attract rich humans rich
humans are basically like veal
conceptually repulsive but so buttery on
my tongue
my search for new wife has not been
going so great i am not a creep i'm just
a very ancient warrior who wishes to
marry you come back
whoops cheers
[Music]
what's the word for what you guys are
polyamorous oh i was thinking filthy
hippies
[Music]
water damage is ruined
not this wood
i still think we should try that old
vampire freestyle wrap again gonna bust
loose on the club roof sucking throat
juice like it's grey goose
fx is what we do in the shadows a genie
lamb i wish you to bring back all 37 of
my dead wives
greetings my wife
premieres july 12th on fx stream on hulu
what's happening we just hit a major
milestone solar opposites are back for
season three
obviously we should reward ourselves but
how i mean pancakes and oral crepes and
rims we do crepes and [ __ ] too much
it's it's not a treat anymore
now that i'm not focusing on the mission
or fixing the ship i'm free to do
whatever i want don't you know who i am
i'm corvo i do the hero [ __ ] around here
oh i've been waiting for this day sounds
like the solar opposites are going to be
having some fun this year
why did you do that that's america [ __ ]
i do what i want
stop stop don't do this please think of
it as your eat pray love help
jesus you aliens get into some stupid
[ __ ]
what the hell i'm supposed to be taking
care of the pupa he does love him some
wacky hijinks okay
let's go
hey i'm falling in love with you i did
seven minutes in heaven with btk oh boy
here we go
[Music]
the aliens have left this is our chance
to escape and get big again you've been
shrinking people and putting them in a
wall oh that rule makes me want to do
two segway into a montage
[Music]
wow i guess cupid's bigger on the inside
holy [ __ ]
stop that train jack [ __ ]
when we first met we were a bunch of
beautiful strangers but now we are
family and we are finally able to do
this sweet-ass tic-tac-toe
let's just be a lesson you mess with the
solar opposite
pay with your life
did we take it too far back there i'd
say we walked right up to the line let's
go what you gonna do with that gargoyle
ray fart face
damn it i'm calling the city before they
turn you into a son of a
[Music]
[ __ ] i just listened to your podcast
i'm black and broke too thanks for
giving my broke ass home anytime girl
[Music]
that's malika jones i'm phoebe hill and
everything's trash so i took the pill
and guess what i'm not pregnant
hey
ladies we were just getting noise bleed
next door i mean we've never tried to
silence females ever not my style no i'm
just saying shh
okay bye thanks so much great
i am a free-spirited young woman who
wears head wraps when i'm having sex
because some dudes are not worth
sweating them edges out over okay ew
phoebe
my whole back has a rug
okay that is not a nice thing to call
your friend no this is her whole bag
it's an emergency go back for mornings
after
this whole crossword puzzle rolled up
sleeves probably have your bills set to
auto pay minimal conversations being
worked well i got you talking to me
you caught feelings uh uh i've been safe
but there's no condom for your heart
don't ever touch my boobs again it was
weird i didn't like it either
life is hard auntie phoebe looks like
she just came from a sleepover party are
you're doing the best you can
and i think i'm okay representing that
you are the brightest damn light i know
[Music]
dear everything's trash we want you to
represent us in a culturous photo shoot
y'all what's more black and excellent
than this benching peanut butter ladies
from hidden figures i mean most popular
music
black excellence is a [ __ ] right
they said the world would end in 2036
but they were wrong
the world ended a long time ago
umbrella
a company besieged by a scandal is now
trying to reinvent itself
[Music]
the old umbrella made mistakes the
things we're working on today they're
gonna change the
[Music]
world we have a problem
[Music]
the drug contains the t-virus
the t-virus can make monsters
billions will die
everyone keep your mouth shut
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
is complicated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
watch me go boy look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thursday july 14th at 10 on bbc america
305
justin
we should start a rock
hey my name is shauna and i'm mia we got
something cooking for y'all
why would a walking talk talk it's me
[Applause]
money maker i should work on this
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what it's about let's go
in the building
we got the opportunity to have a good
time
and when
we in the middle of a bad [ __ ]
renaissance
that's my party going down
what kind of part did you be in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm gonna do
[Music]
[Applause]
has
[Applause]
[Music]
aah
[Applause]
doing bad things to you
[Applause]
right let's go let's go let's go
are you sure you don't just want to
shave it all off
shave your head get rid of here no okay
well i'm going to keep checking back
how things mean with the children oh we
adore them though princess is a
four foot seven inch ball of energy
oh my god do they have the faces of
angels i bet they have the faces of
angels yeah do they totally love you yet
but they totally love you don't they i
still haven't bonded promptly with them
who wants to put up a tent
i'm not fun enough where's princess gone
princess you never do anything by the
book and it always works out i do
everything by the book and it never
works oh oh my god did i buy the wrong
bloody book
i cannot believe that he supports
arsenal i don't belong here oh he's
young switch him to spurs he's already
said and anyway i'd rather he was an
arsenal fan than someone who switches
teams i mean that's like cheating on
your wife
sorry mate no offense
you're selling our flat your tenancy
runs out in three months it's only a few
weeks until we go before the judge does
that mean we're gonna lose custody of
the kids the council wants stable
families
what what we gonna do
everything's gonna be okay i mean how do
we know that they even wanna stay with
us
because we have a good
love
one that can survive life
[Music]
love doesn't just happen to you it's
hard work
if you want it
you'll find it
you're not being me are you to do that
you need to fully understand my um
philosophy of life
you rarely hear a phrase like that
coming from someone eating two
children's yogurts
[Music]
so what brings you to tacoma
vacation from the kids oh no kids that
ship has sailed it's our 10-year
anniversary safety
as they will get you everything you need
oh even heroin sorry just joking that's
a bad joke i'm starting to forget who i
am no work
no stress no regrets
when would you see where this leads us
[Music]
this phone belonged to a kid who went
missing down here 15 years ago
and belonged to sam walford
sam and his mom and his dad and his
girlfriend arrived at this resort on
christmas night
but then the next morning he's gone
later on this other guest from the
resort was also reported missing
do you want to get out of here
my daughter wanted to spend christmas
here
but she didn't want to spend it with me
we found a boy skateboard
you ever feel like something from the
past is missing from your future
i'm gonna get some answers
hey come back here
or what if there aren't any answers
well there have to be
because otherwise what is the [ __ ]
point
sophia are you ready to begin
take me back
where were you before
and before that
and before that
can you keep going
do you know what it feels like
to not remember anything
everyone keeps telling me who they think
i am
to fresh starts but if my life was so
perfect why did i try to end it
[Music]
sophie it's time to move forward but i
need to know what really happened we do
know no we think we know based on what
we think happened
what if i didn't jump
was there anything unusual about that
day
you were saying all kinds of crazy
things a man pushed you from the boat
your id said one name and you kept
insisting it was something else
it's the darkest
people with perfect lives don't usually
jump off of fairies
daily accident your husband's alibi is a
lie if you're starting to remember some
things that must be really scary
sometimes it's hard not knowing you're
in secrets
we can't just pretend we're new people
[Music]
or that the past doesn't exist
[Music]
you really don't remember dave your
husband's not really thinking
why did you lie she's starting to ask
questions i can't answer
maybe i was wrong about everything
sophie what's going on
just
putting the pieces together
it's so perfect
this is some kind of time travel we're
in 2019
we're gonna get back to 1988.
who's there
what are you doing in my house what are
you doing in my house that's her
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
okay this isn't real this isn't real
this is real
[Music]
[Applause]
you took my dreams you took my heart you
made me love you from
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you